okay I got hit your boy psychobabble
here playing a little game called the
kid the Cape a bass the cave okay
it's a cube escape game the last one so
far shark rest I like presents
uh hello though I like your hat quick
day you can't wear it down there
oh it's lent a 1972 hey sir
yeah can I have you
okay hey it's a talk from roots oh well
there's way too many things going on
already huh
anything in your bone now would he want
something obvious like he wants some
food anything here can I flip this now I
guess I can you know I took the Pedro -
is hello - as a knife that's locked
I cannot hell up at and this is screwed
out his leg help and I like I what if I
cut but I can't you're screwed I can't
pop Aaron cuz there's a thing there what
is that
drag what is it Oh
I see now had a reset
um could I miss the party what happens
for it just keep going higher and higher
can I write do I need the chisel I guess
I need a can share a little stuff but
what is this
hello sir mr. bat was from hotel salary
comes from stabbed this sucker
what okay okay what is that fire pit
and he clear this
um and there's different colors
what is this one had I reset that okay
Wow I horribly added that hardly wrong
okay what is this pot
mmm hello mrs. better
wait what's wrong
[Music]
if I had destroyed I would keep him safe
[Music]
adios muchacho
[Music]
yeah okay I'm getting this I'll get to
make sure they all left
no he got me okay
this is tricky actually
okay Sam I'm a genius
great sucks three you Mizar spider oh
great whoo I just caught it myself
okay oh you can just trap him I got the
puck hello sir
I need my drink and I had my drink
all right how do I get that
okay there's that a whole a couple of
these guys
I don't know how he catches the mold
it's just like not I'll say it again
what is this drag the symbols yeah okay
hello sir
anything in there
well the books gotta go here
chapter 1 the van der blooms the last
credit elixir of life and death how do i
how do I get over there
all right we're in I just I remember
this this I played roots
luckily itis here their faces are like
shaped there this guy was one of the
last but he had like a word kid I guess
is Albert fincas jams Emma killed
herself
yeah I guess is marry Samuel rose
or his last one yeah Oh Lara actually is
a kid between two rows that makes a lot
of sense
[Music]
okay that's just simple I gotta make
okay
[Music]
mmm
I'm so talented
okay at their door one of the month was
this last Ari
hello sir what
let's have this puzzle and
you're like damn apples Oh you drank it
yeah he died and it made the tree which
may ended up with Lara wind it up
he turned to the crow Wow a lot of
things that explained here oh my god
that makes a lot of sense
okay I guess the Cape was after roots I
guess should I cook this thing or shy
you feed you to shine
no talking I'm a petri dish
grind this thing up
maybe the bad ones that okay how do you
get these things
anyway to the buck
okay hey a spy what
south Samba so deliciously simple man I
can't keep up with all the stuff okay
what sir what
hex is supposed to do
[Music]
um okay wait this goes over here which
goes over here safe okay
get over there
okay this guy try this white got got gun
okay little more of a this guy is right
here
ah
[Music]
I have it
all right Jamie we're gonna solve this
okay
what the heck head around chisel this oh
this one are moveset okay this is making
more sense
[Music]
I was like how 90 more that got here
again you know a lot faster
[Music]
okay black
Vennela black
chocolate black black chocolate
chocolate
[Music]
black
Vennela black oh it's a bird a hey Brad
a
because that down hey can I help me out
[Music]
okay I need my drink any of these stupid
box
Thank You minute cliff I am it's still
jacked up
trying to solve Chapter two before going
and you get that pictures
[Music]
[Music]
right
the extract last elixir dog from the dog
you get something which you look in
there and turn to the bird
oh yeah cuz the dog drank it I forgot
where is that much
and you get this guy
down okay
I literally did not know that was from
that one puzzle one is that where's this
what the heck
there is how about I see you why do you
go
trying to help me buddy I don't know how
can I take this now feel like I should
get a prize from this
I do a noon
wait this is yellow there's one yellow
Oh whether they say the shape on I got
to square just see real quick
bluh
tread
I think that's gray
blue
[Music]
thatõs just wait that's it yeah okay
okay square that's right
where's red
is your circle so let's just go through
his until one clicks it okay okay it
looks like we're making a lot of
progress
yeah he's stupid animal
bottled water okay so that PI goes with
D this thing what
[Music]
great what just happened I just lose my
thing
[Music]
now if I put in there
oh geez Louise do you know I gotta kill
ya
oh can i chip the wall this now yeah
hello sorry there's a knife right there
you cut it off cut it off and get good
again
hey that's the doll baby yeah he doesn't
eat arms
[Music]
give us of the bat no yeah right you go
make some silly putty paste right here
dog food
oh my god that is disgusting right you
gotta do what you gotta do to survive in
this world you're in a cave you know
yeah dog eh yeah you like that don't ya
oh oh
a dog turd alright to grind this I don't
think I need to I think it's not
grinding for it today yep okay the turn
in there oh great
well I do not want to mess with that
Eddy
and I know that the symbol is it's gotta
be the book right
I sell in Chapter two no one actually
knows what chapter I'm on heck and I
even know I chapter I'm on ok is that
like a symbol anyway
that could show you as a Samba I need my
drink I'll shake it out maybe I should
have to untangle up what is this now
ah
okay it's probably just no simple enough
to untangle it or something no not have
to be crossing that thing say they sure
like red how great guys are doing a lot
of this today
this is gonna be a nightmare
wait spread these bad boys out
there we go
Allen one sees a great
how the heck oh my god I want to go
insane doing this
[Music]
um yeah at least a highlight which ones
crossing
right
this is the worst thing I've ever seen
and
[Music]
okay hey Nate says drag Oh
[Music]
mr. Crowl
you know you got his drink alright okay
I can't be playing games with him all
day you know I just can't
I just got dog that died for that yeah
you got okay
[Music]
a new picture on the wall yes
what the heck is this
[Music]
okay that's grab a can order
well now they can order somewhere um
here
[Music]
bird wood bird creatures would fish
[Music]
Cheers
[Music]
how are the fish pointing to where I
gotta go yeah okay the fish I liked I'm
gonna go
[Music]
and thank goodness for you fish thank
goodness for you fish
[Music]
or my dad died liquid metal I use that
the rank decay I don't know why I do
this because I think this was in another
game
Gobert skew escape okay
what is that tape okay it looks like I
live today but it looks like you're
gonna live today sure yeah go yeah
that's disgusting buddy yeah mr. Howell
dance journey is about to start
you have to gather the memories we need
them for our future there is this yep
thank you for the diamond dolls are they
care for the card yep Hey
[Music]
and I get just an ass crap right I go
this way okay
what
how that great
you know the picture on the wall yeah
Reds gotta go this way and things gotta
go that way okay maybe I get that
area backwards
that's here
that's it yeah what say part you're the
game
deaf 4003 left and to down
great and we gotta just move they're
wrong okay
they laughed yeah
[Music]
emptying pot do not know what goes there
what was that I need that where'd it go
this is getting very sophisticated
okay
okay dunno what that has ever meant to
help fishing one point and what the heck
is this
it's just where the diamond came from in
the lake game
well I have no idea forty
nothing's there and as usual I have no
idea what's going on okay
ah came back to here again I I really
don't know what is going on now oh there
should be 40 and I lower this
oh okay three
should be 2 and a 3
what is that
see how the map just like a second ago
deaf is 43 that left to down
Oh
from this go through the left one two
three
well that gratis once
what what I know this might want oh my
god
wait what was the coordinates of this
right here X is 3 y is 5
what the heck is that why is that
can I say something now yeah go go 40
and I got no idea what is going on here
no idea then uh Dan what and I didn't
hear any more
what the egg
okay can I see anything now
now but I do what I do
I think I just do
and I have no clue mm-hmm I think she's
like moving
okay did we move we're over there now
and that one
holy crap I think one North how I change
direction
does anyone know how to change direction
yeah yeah yeah
okay so I've gone completely north how
do I not go north anymore anything and a
device that you may have for my I walk a
lot I take it I don't know what that
means
to be honest I have not clue
we're still north as heck we cannot be
any more north how do I change direction
and it will change the direction where
I'm gonna be nobody knows how much I
don't wanna be in this direction yeah I
guess there's a strength
this is like the direction how do I make
it Oh what what yeah we go okay so
that's how you change directions so I
gotta go one two three four five five
South let's do this let's crank this
thing baby to eleven now that somebody
taught us how to remove this thing come
on come on baby come on baby and out the
dough here yes okay
West one two three four four hello baby
why can't I change this why can't I
change this
oh crap there were my sappers am I
yeah that's right there any like say it
or something
Oh
how
okay ah hi that right as ah hi
are gone straight for it whatever it is
come on one more baby holy Toledo
where is that
we are right on top of this thing we're
the wrong death oh yeah holy Toledo
we got it we got it
Oh what the heck
ship it
all right
okay
that's great now where's the Kip yep
uh half a okay yeah I extracted her body
okay now what I do this fish nice tear
fast you want to go in here I'm talking
to him I start fresh
donate three fish and another nice fish
I doubt Jesus
count Brasky
oh hey got it boy I got it so fat are
they screaming non-date for that
okay
what is the problem here that really
share what the problem is here
am i so many combos
I like this
one of these guys got a guy coupler huh
okay
palek I'm missing the Chloe air but so
nice was about here
am I crazy or is there another fish oh
great there's another fish
what's gonna happen
what
bro
any tell them I fetched Johnny
know how much fish am I gonna eat here I
like shays us one more fish one more to
roll them all
yeah I ain't freaking a mess he's so
ugly and we really hate him for being
ugly
this is weird yeah watch my hand out of
this
they all got to be balanced are they
holy cannoli is unbalanced no I don't
think I'd change anything uh oh well
yeah while he says EPS
I thought hell yeah what the heck mister
crap get over here nice tie crap where
is he go if I just let me go that way
what
so I'm gonna tell that Crowder stop
fooling around that she'll do yeah I
need that Wow
yeah beautiful miss that crab you've
always been beautiful triangle def Rd
great without do this again def is the
pouch devastate
wait oh yeah huh
like this
helps
that and actually there
right now SMS
no it's like way more zoomed out it's
like the hotel and that farmhouse the
hotels away over there how they make
this bigger deaf 30
what the heck
and I flipped this
so that's really how it is
this spot at deaf 30 x2 y2
okay this whole thing again getting a
left once what what happened
okay one two three
north three times
[Music]
perfect we get what was a deaf dirty
perfect oh my god this is just asking
in a desk app I know what that's down
there I created Scott's tight now Can I
grab weird okay
and look they're here doing crap out
here yeah here it is
you know this way start right there
well BAE blah I love that mummy thank
you
Kang what was next
is that it all right good luck Hank he
opening awfully quiet this whole time
mister any other writer hope
oh he's doing okay what I had a right
ow
is at the L
crap
what am I supposed to write I know you
expect my language
what are you saying I don't speak your
language any bucks honey I gotta read
that looks like the whole fate lies in
this guy up down what do ya end it all
right down
huh okay wait what stay
Oh
dot that then
and place time where there's an end
what the heck it's so dumb
hey directions give it to freakin
directions I can't say up
okay I know this game now okay dot so
long
where's the f
I think got it right sit thank God okay
I
and okay Inc okay
what do I do with thank well very funny
very funny can I put this egg on you
what what do you want me to do with this
egg sanity Oh des des des
so funny jokers out there I felt like I
solved the puzzle yeah yeah chef's
attempt Shepard to him
I can't take back time can i I hear ya I
hear you loud and clear buddy you
literally are spelling enough for me
it resets every time Jesus how do I can
I get it like shipped to him and now he
wants the egg Oh actually I wants to
make
sarahott bangers dark out out bang
Outback sounding an English ain't it
sorry sorry I don't know what the heck
you want how do I got the egg to him
and I get to Hank to him I know it wants
to ink ink inkay ink and gang egg out oh
my god this is it I'm gonna go insane
now now
you gotta be kidding me
that's disgusting
what
oh okay I know this game plays now I
know this game plays okay I got the
stupid egg I got your stupid egg
tell me what's a downtown stuff focusing
on that stepanak yeah what kind of
hideout for you is it this thing I
haven't used thing at all come on I got
your egg up right there what is that
X 4 y 6
what's the deaf
okay
go east too
this sector so long there's nothing to
do with the cave South one two three
four four
oh crap was definite zero
I say yeah why's are two black cubes I
look so bad
sufficient go on that side but that's
what craziness is here what time is that
what's hurting right yeah
holy cannoli
what the heck
ah
how the heck can I get this line up oh
okay
what the heck not thank you so what
happens now
I just go on our merry way there's a
hook there I see that Minister crap tell
us right I go what I do the matches
[Music]
sarah has a lot of call for
oops
now mr. Schock why are you get
jump-scare me yeah it's got a job
scamming
like quiet huh I said let out a sir
what t:k I to get
all right
nice shake huh aah sorry aah get it get
it
Oh grant otherwise Thanks three and one
on Joe three what is that
X 3 y 4
Jesse not Great North too
it's the Lowen
last one
yeah I wonder if this is a way to like
um keep you from like looking at the
window would have changes swear it Abe
oh my god what happened
oh no luck a lot of the Kravis on
okay well I got the cab's how's that a
bear that can a pisser
yeah
know what is going on here
[Music]
he's a bad dad as a bad
[Music]
hey I got that [ __ ]
shows about that
[Music]
[Music]
no way that's crazy
anyways nice to watch and help I like
this game
thank you